raspberry pi
a computer that fits in the palm of your
hand with a price tag
as low as five dollars the idea was born
in 2006 and the first commercial unit
was launched in 2012
and since then it's evolved into one of
the best selling computers in the world
it's named raspberry because computer
companies like to name themselves after
fruit and
pie for the python programming language
not only is the computer tiny but it can
also be quite powerful
with a quad core processor and up to
eight gigabytes of ram they're great for
building your own iot prototypes robots
security cameras web servers and many
other fun projects
when you unbox your raspberry pi 4
you'll notice a bunch of little chips
and connectors
in the center we have our cpu and ram
that is the brain of the operation
nearby is the wi-fi bluetooth module
that can wirelessly connect to the
outside world
at the top we have a general purpose
input output connector
for connecting other electrical devices
to the right we have an ethernet
connection along with four usb ports
on the bottom we have an audio jack two
connect speakers or headphones
a csi camera connector for building your
own custom camera
micro hdmi ports for connecting multiple
monitors
and finally a usb c port to provide
power to the computer but most
importantly
flip the raspberry pi over to find the
micro sd slot
think of it as a hard drive that
contains the operating system required
to
interface with the hardware you can use
the raspberry pi like a normal desktop
computer
by connecting a keyboard mouse and
monitor when you power it up the first
time you can install
any operating system you'd like but most
beginners will take advantage of the
noobs installer
which installs a flavor of linux called
raspberry pi os
now that you're in you can program it to
take over the world you might connect
some leds to the gpio header then
control them with a python script or you
might add a camera then connect to wi-fi
to build your own home security system
from scratch
the possibilities are limited only by
your imagination
this has been raspberry pi in 100
seconds if you enjoy these short videos
please make sure to hit the like button
and subscribe
it really helps out and if you want to
see more raspberry pi content let me
know in the comments
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one